if you are a science teacher with a
student who's whose parents insist that
he or she not be exposed to biology to
evolution I'm not sure what the rules
are you I know you can
there's lawsuits pending in a couple
states I get emails every week from the
National Council for science education
the NCSC addressing lawsuits about this
issue but yes it's let your passion come
through is a hard thing to find a kid
who doesn't love dinosaurs
and there must there's probably one but
I've never met him or her so I would
start there the ancient dinosaurs very
much like modern birds and there's
reasons for that one thing led to the
other the other thing I just remind
everybody about to a lesser extent this
guy Alfred Wallace but Charles Darwin
was disciplined I mean he did these
extraordinary experiments this series of
experiments to discover to understand
the process of change from generation to
generation and this change is all around
us and the other just really hard thing
for people who who haven't taken time
and this will be a pun to understand the
amount of time involved we live less
than a century a human does but this
process that brought us to be is
billions of years old and it's just
really hard to get your mind around what
that means billion years 65 million
years and the other thing that's just
out of our everyday experience as people
we design things and make them we decide
how big the piece of paper is we decide
how large our handwriting is going to be
then we make an organization chart for
our corporation and then we hire people
and it's it's top-down its idea down but
evolution doesn't work that
whay evolution is bottom-up evolution is
in the poetic sense organic and literate
in the chemical sense literally organic
all these systems emerge all these
living things emerge and the good ones
the good designs eat the bad designs and
so there's no more bad designs there's
just good designs then the designs
compete and then the eat each other and
so you very quickly and people run
computer models about this you very
quickly end up with an ecosystem and
tuned tune species it's it is out of our
everyday experience it is not top-down
although maybe I will digress on this
maybe with the social networking that
happens now it is organic it is
bottom-up in another sense that the
self-organizing systems come into place
let's all have a flash mob okay there's
no manager of flash mobbing it just
emerges and if it's a stupid flash mob
nobody shows up so then that one's
eliminated if it's big fun like what's
the one everybody likes is thrower
dancing - thrower yeah 200 people show
up to pretend to be Michael Jackson okay
it's self-organizing is what I'm going
for and that's what evolution is the bad
designs get eaten by the good ones and
so all you have is good ones it happens
very fast
you